it's
a my honor to introduce you a great man
that's a habit because i got to also
introduce natasha
not a great man a great woman
richard corcoran is the florida florida
education commissioner
it has purview over k through 12.
he's one of the best in the country at
his job
which is not quite damning with faint
praise because there's two or three that
are pretty good
his wife is a classical education woman
herself and a mother of six
his father was a soldier and he was in
the army reserve
the cool thing about him in my opinion
is that i learned about
uh six years ago
because we got into education reform and
founding charter schools
and the the best place in the country to
do it is florida and i started learning
how that came to be
first i met a name a man named michael
baleka who was speaker of the florida
house
and then i met our speaker today who
michael baleka success
who did you succeed michael or did he
succeed you
i see he was he he was uh they were in
the hot
in the house florida house at the same
time and then of course the great ron
desantis
and they have been step by step
reforming the charter school laws in
in florida so that you can do it and
there are a lot of detailed things that
have to be done like
uh charter schools are public schools
they have a measure of independence from
the government and
how wide that measure is at the decisive
factor
but also when does the education money
come to the school and in what quantity
so you can actually do it
and they just have been working on that
and figuring it out and
coming to see that for years
and they have made florida a paradise
for charter education
and they're still working on it
i was impressed more than anything else
about the acts of friendship that have
gone on that have kept
continuity in that effort because that's
very difficult stuff to do
to stand up against the constant
bureaucratization of everything in the
country
to try to liberate people to do
wonderful jobs like
running schools and raising their own
children
that is in the short term often a
thankless task
and it takes a lot of skill and
commitment and it's rare to see people
who sustain that together for so long
and that's what's happened in florida
and we're going to hear about whatever
richard corcoran wants to say but i will
say that he is one of the most important
men
in the united states today and we are
honored to have him here
richard corcoran
[Applause]
first i would just say it's a great
honor to be at hillsdale college
obviously
being a conservative all my life uh
hillsdale has played an active role in
and whether it's just
the monthly and primus or people i've
known who come to hillsdale watching the
speakers
it's a fantastic college and you guys
we've been here two days
just fantastic meetings with the faculty
with dr arn
so it's a it's a pleasure to be here
i'll give you one warning though before
i start
and when you're speaker of the house and
then became an education commissioner
you get invited and so i was invited to
go to a nursing home
and give a speech on american
exceptionalism and so i thought okay
i'll do that
and they had all the residents gathered
and i'd give the speech and talk about
american exceptionalism and then the
director said there was one gentleman
who was too sick
he couldn't make it out of his room and
he asked if you'd be kind enough to give
him a speech
and so i thought okay so i went into his
room and i gave
of course i shortened it and i gave him
the speech and i'm trying to say all
these like important lines about
american exceptional and he just won't
even look at me
won't budge won't move i say another one
nothing
i get done with the speech nothing and
so finally as i'm walking to the door i
think i got to say something
to this gentleman and so i turned to him
and i said sir
i really really hope you get better and
he kind of pops up in his bed he goes i
hope you do too
[Laughter]
so i i always like to warn an audience
before i speak because it's
now you've been fairly warned um i do
want to talk though
a little bit which is you know at this
uh
colleges you guys could lecture you know
ad nauseam
me on the topic but i grew up with two
parents my parents were older
both have passed both had very difficult
lives
my dad was orphaned when he was two grew
up in
orphanages and and foster homes went
into world war ii
um and then uh after world war ii
um got into the foreign service my
mother
grew up in england during the great
depression
their family went through the entire
crash um they had no money and so her
father took a job as a
managing a tea plantation in india and
that's where she was actually born in
darjeeling
and so but they grew up and so they
would always say to us in these two
you know pivotal moments in time a great
depression and world war ii
and so all we would ever hear was
philosophy was everything
you ought to have a philosophy what is
your philosophy and it could be anything
you know if you're thinking about having
children what's your philosophy on how
what do they look like at 18 what's your
philosophy and work what's your
philosophy in
all aspects of life that philosophy was
everything
and and because their lives were
completely
altered changed and and controlled by
the philosophies of others
both economically and physically and so
they would say either you have a
philosophy
or you don't but if you don't that's
okay but someone else has one
and you will absolutely be moved by
their philosophy and so all of that
you know just spawned that rich thought
throughout
we would literally have conversations
and say is man good or bad
we would have to answer that question
and then when i became a speaker later
in life you
these philosophies start coming together
and you realize that
i will tell you the best legislators
that i would serve with the ones who
really understood the role of government
and and what it means to be a successful
self-governing society would be ones
that would say that man was inherently
um was inherently bad as opposed to
inherently good the ones who were
inherently good were the ones who would
constantly come up with the great
society and everything along those lines
on a microcosm at a state level so
getting the position of education the
first thing i thought was what
what is the philosophy of education and
and the sad truth
many of them conservatives how many
times are we here we need more welders
than philosophers
what is the purpose of education and the
modern day even among republican
rank and file version of education is
it's a means to a job
a career or something along those lines
and it's so much more and so
um and i didn't even know this until i
spent time with dr arn today
but obviously one of my uh favorite
folks that i have followed throughout
time is frederick douglass and i did not
know he had been on this campus twice
and and have tremendous
statues and and quotes and what have you
about frederick douglass but he has the
greatest quote of education when i took
over the education commissioner
the first thing i did was tear down most
of the stuff in the in the building
and i put up huge quotes one by
washington and one by
frederick douglass because i thought i
wanted everyone who walked into the
building to understand what the
philosophy and the purpose of education
was
and but he has this just fantastic quote
i'll paraphrase
where he says education is freedom this
is a guy who escaped slavery
came to the north he goes education is
freedom it's emancipation
it is the uplifting of the human soul to
the glorious light of truth
and to deny any individual a a
world-class education
is the greatest crime against humanity
and and so when you think about what
education is and
again nobody knows it better than
hillsdale but it is about creating great
citizens
people you look at the fortune 500 ceos
and they all say
we want people who can critically think
who can problem solve who can
communicate we really don't care what
their degree is in
steve jobs is you know i always quote
steve jobs because people look at me and
like oh you're just you know
a liberal arts you know guy you don't
really understand
the role of stem or in in society
but the i said okay well let's take the
first trillion dollar company in america
is apple
the ceo of apple also educated in a
liberal arts school
for the time he was there where she
found you know helvetica
text and that came the formation of the
the apple computer text
but he would say they said to him why
how did you become the first trillion
dollar company
and he would say it was easy because all
the other companies microsoft oracle
name them all
they're computer science companies and
this is on youtube they're computer
science companies he says apple
we exist at the intersection of computer
science and liberal arts
this i can teach you and i probably
would rather do it i don't i'd rather
not have to detox you from whatever you
learned in college or wherever you're
from
this i can't teach either you have it or
you don't and that's why everything you
look at apple
everything they did every advertisement
it was never about selling computers to
the point now that you have guys
who have become millionaires writing
books about steve jobs
why but he's literally just saying that
this is the why that steve jobs had
about the liberal arts
and and computer science intersection
but what it what it did
was he would sell you know think
different you know
it's going to change your life his
famous commercial about where the
were the crazy ones you can't ignore us
you can't you know
narrated by richard dreyfus it was this
whole concept of
as dr aaron was saying earlier it's the
true the good and the beautiful and
that's
what built him to this beautiful
trillion dollar company and so
all of that gets to the two points i do
want to impress upon you
as i got to the department is that now
you know the philosophy you know
the one thing that we can do um
to change people's lives we can't we
talked about it last night
we can't force everyone to be raised in
a two-parent home but we know that the
the consequences or the derivative of
that is just enormous
but what we can do and what we are doing
is trying to give every child that
world-class education help them become
good citizens good spouses
good community leaders and and recognize
the value and inherent value of an
education
but but we're not there and and not only
not there we struggle
more and more and more to get there and
so i'll give you
the facts in florida and on the national
assessment of education progress which
all the states take
we're in the top four for reading in
fourth grade
the number ones is massachusetts pretty
perennially
i think it's going to change as a result
of covid because we're the only state
that opened up our schools face-to-face
instruction to any child who wanted it
uh boston still closed and so but
massachusetts is number one they're
number one and they're like 45
on the nape exam at or above basic um
which means i always say 55
the number one state and the richest
country in the history of mankind the
number one state has 55 percent give or
take florida we're like at 39 so we're
over 60 percent of our fourth graders
that are somewhat partially or fully
illiterate
and so now take florida we have our own
state assessment we give in third grade
and our third grade assessment we
basically have similar numbers
42 44 of our third graders
in english are either partially fully
illiterate
um they're getting ones and twos
and when you have that um
what you're doing in a society is you're
not only are you creating people who
have no concept of what it means to
self-govern or be a citizen
they have no hope and the most
dangerous person in any realm a society
in life in in a school yard wherever it
doesn't matter
take hope away from a human being and
they become extremely extremely
dangerous and i think you see that play
itself out
and so how do you move that you know i i
say to my staff all the time we ought to
just send letters
to every single third grade parent which
is literally
you know 55 percent of them and say
hey dear mrs jones billy's a great kid
enjoyed
having him in class but here's the
bottom line
there's no hope for him he's he's toast
there's nothing we can do
because we know this fact too if you're
a one in two in third grade
because we have 20 years of
accountability history then i asked my
staff give me every single graduate
of third grade that became a 10th grader
because now we have 20 years of history
and tell me what they were in 20 and
10th grade the last time we give the
esa exam and guess what 86 percent who
are ones and twos either partially or
functionally illiterate
are partially or functionally illiterate
in 10th grade
and the only thing that changes them
obviously hillsdale is a significant
factor
if they move to some other the three
things that changed education in america
accountability number one more than
anything else choice number two but if
they
somehow find their way into a choice
school an excellent choice school
if they somehow find an excellent
teacher maybe they get a seventh grade
middle school hillsdale graduate who
says and what what they're going to do
is they're going to go back
and start like get kindergarten first
and second grade and get those
children caught up but otherwise 86
are still functioning illiterate
the converse is true if you're a three
four or five it's about 85 percent or
still three fours and five so whatever
happens between pre-k
or birth and third grade once we lose
them there we lose them for life
and they become what i would say is not
all of them but a lot of them become
very very dangerous
um and and that's a problem and so how
do you fix it
the what we have done in florida and
moving to do in florida is we're going
all in the stats are just as you dig
into it more and more the stats are
staggering 61 percent of low-income kids
don't have a single book in their home
and if they don't have a single book in
their home that's no one's reading to
them
if a parent most of you guys have
probably read to your children at least
20 minutes a day but that's the minimal
goal we try to say 20 minutes a day
if you read 20 minutes a day to your
child they finish in the top 10 percent
statistically on standardized tests if
you read one minute a day to your child
or no minutes a day to your child
they basically are the corpus of your
your dropouts your failures and and or
your illiterate population
and so if we don't go all in and and
wrestle with those kids in that pre-k to
third grade realm we were talking the
other night and i said if i was to do
something else
much like hillsdale's doing i'd love to
see the same hillsdale
model but to rapidly expand and go into
pre-k to third grade and and go into
every single state as fast as we can in
a big way because we know
that once we lose them in third grade we
lose them for life um
so that's we're doing everything we're
trying to do a peace corps and have
great graduates like hillsdale go in and
read to these kids from
pre-k to third grade we're having
literally a book a month club
these kids are very poor they've never
had it i know for me when i get the
amazon truck pull in and i know it's a
new golf club or something i'm pretty
excited
you know so imagine a child who's n
doesn't even have
celebrate christmas now having a book
delivered to his house on a daily basis
and that book's tied to our standards
that we completely rewrote
and it's content rich and so not only
are they
getting that great literature they're
learning the same book in school
at the same time with their mentors all
at the same time
and and it's hopefully we'll we'll have
that effect we've also
basically john all in on the science of
reading um you know
modern day we we all recognize that this
the
social experiment of whole language was
an abject failure
but even now we don't call it whole
language now we have great terms blended
literacy whatever
but it's up and down in our schools all
across america not obviously in
hillsdale charter schools or any
classical school for that matter
but if we don't have that phonics and
the phonemic awareness and the literacy
and
the fluency and the vocabulary you're
never going to get the comprehension and
so
we're going all in and fighting with our
publishers that we will not have a
single
textbook in a classroom that doesn't
have the science of reading
hopefully all of that stuff and we'll
start seeing quickly
improvements in our in our students
education so
i know that um it sounds uh
as an aside to that i'll tell you having
been in the legislature it's an amazing
thing in education
and and you guys have seen it as you go
into other states but
when i was in the legislature if
somebody came before and i was on an
environmental committee and they said
hey we have
this magic potion we can drop it in lake
okeechobee and immediately there'll be
no blue-green algae
there'd be absolute outcry people would
be upset
they'd almost be thrown out of the
committee this is ridiculous we would
have to study that for six or seven
years we'd want to make sure
everything was done correctly and all
our scientific data was correct
this will never happen in the next six
or seven years now conversely go to an
education committee and somebody comes
in and says
we have this magic potion if we put it
in schools tomorrow
our kids will just be phenomenal
students they're like let's try it i
mean there's no
there's no screening or testing or
anything to the point that when you look
at america on the pisa
national where we compete with the rest
of the world
america you know we're like 24th 28th
and like 35th in math science and
in english you know just abysmal but
when they did the study and they looked
at what does america do great it the
the just wonderful irony which we still
do today
the two things that america everyone
says nobody can compete with
number one is we have the prettiest
buildings you know and so to quote you
know you can
teach plato under a tree we don't even
teach plato but we have a beautiful
building so don't worry about going
under the tree and learning something
and then the second part is that we have
absolutely without question more tech in
classrooms than anybody else
and it's been quite frankly
overwhelmingly
a failure not a success and so those are
the two things we score well even though
we're 24 28th and 29th
all of that to say um my dad and mom
i started with them i do think there's
optimism i was talking
a lot to dr arno about it you know with
the universities and colleges and we
have a whole
group of folks that are board of
directors from flagler college trying to
how do you
how do you replicate what hillsdale's
done is it possible and can it be
sustainable and
and all of those questions and dr arn
you know basically said
quoting churchill but there's there is
hope you know if they're they're
formed on a broken truth and so there is
hope for us to
to crash that and that's something my
father and mother would tell you
probably i don't know if you've heard
this but
my dad would always say there's two
little boys one's an eternal optimist
and one's an eternal pessimist
and so they go and they get studied by
doctors and they say let's put the
optimus boy in a room with a pile of
manure
and let's take the pessimist boy and put
him in a room with toys candies
and everything under the sun and they
put the boys in the room
they check on them and they see the boy
in the the pessimist first and they go
in and he's cowering
in the corner of a room like little boy
why aren't you you know playing with the
candy and he's like i might get sick
you know why don't you play with the
toys i don't know the buttons i could
swallow a button
it's like okay that's a lost cause let's
go check on the optimistic boy
and they go check on the optimistic boy
and they look in the window and he's
jumping up and down he's throwing the
manure
everywhere it's on the ceiling it's all
over his body they go rushing into the
room and they're like little boy whoa
what are you doing don't you know it's a
pile of manure he goes yeah but with all
this manure there's got to be a pony
somewhere
and and so with that analogy or or
anecdote and with the ending with
frederick douglass
in that um it is far easier to raise up
healthy children than it is to fix
broken men
another frederick douglass quote um but
the the
you know the the pony in the story is
what you guys are doing what hillsdale's
doing what
you know all of you are doing educating
the educators who will be in those
schools
um it will hopefully change our country
and sustain us for another 230 years at
least that's the hope
so thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you commissioner corcoran we now
have time for some q a
if you have a question please raise your
hand and wait for a microphone to be
brought to you
terrific talk um so i'm
on the board of northwest ohio classical
academy
a bcasi school opened two years ago
our outcomes are good and that is
certainly one of the motivations
to do the very heavy lift but the second
motivation is
to encourage others who may not
necessarily
want a particularly classical education
from the bourne and charter school to
see them make
good choices is there any reason for
to believe that that will happen
that even if they're not a barney
charter school
we got 24 we got 48 million kids
k through 12.
we need to change there needs to be a
vast change
in in the educational system um
so our kids will prosper that's great
that's the first motivation but the
second motivation is
we're hoping that others will make some
good choices where they're not making it
are we having that effect not
necessarily born a charter school
but just in florida are you making
do you see schools changing for the
better
absolutely but but it's it's it's
volatile
you know so we just won a gubernatorial
race by 30 000 votes in a state with 21
plus million people
um and flip that 30 000 votes i mean if
you followed uh
ron desantis's opponent andrew gillum i
mean what happened to him afterwards i
mean we were that close
and if andrew gillum became the governor
um along comes gwen graham and all of
the the radical left and
and what they do to our school system
what we've had in florida that's worked
and we've had numerous whether you go
back to desantis 30
um you know less than one percent rick
scott reelect less than one percent
first election less than one percent
you know for whatever reason we barely
win these governor's races but have won
them since 1998.
so we've had a long run of republican
governors and a long run of reform
so yes when governor desantis gets
elected he can immediately say okay
we're going to eliminate common core
we're going to rewrite the standards
we're going to make them content rich
we're going to have the science of
reading embedded into our in our
into our standards we're going to
increase accountability increase choice
we just we just got done friday from the
legislative session and passed another
1.2 million kids are eligible
for choice in florida so
it it happens but i will tell you
leadership is everything
and as soon as that leadership changes
everything else does too
unfortunately but that's that's the
reality mcchrystal would say you know
i i have all these kernels you know i
have 20 of them
i i could take the best colonel with the
worst
with the best troop and the worst kernel
with the with the worst troop and i
could switch them
and immediately the best colonel is
going to have the best troop and the
worst general is going to the worst
colonel is going to have the worst troop
and it's the same and that's not even
ideal as as ideological
but in the world that we live in
education it's 100 ideological so
in no time what we have to do is cross
the rubicon and we're
very close when i always say the three
things that have changed
education are accountability has
absolutely
the second we flipped on the lights and
a parent became aware that that
because i liked the teacher she was very
nice the principal was nice carline
functioned well
and i dropped my kid off and they seemed
to be learning they were bringing back
work packets and then all of a sudden
we flip on the light and say say that's
an f school immediately
change happened um and and and people
became
uh frustrated and angry and and so
that's really changed florida more than
anything
second was just this advancement of
choice so we have about three million
school children
um if we can ever get to 1.5 across that
rubicon
we're probably there now with about half
a million children in choice because
we can't we even if you had a gwen
graham or
andrew gillum or whoever come in a nancy
pelosi in florida
you can't take those 500 000 kids and
and bring them back into the public
school system
um so you have to keep doing what we're
doing as quickly as we're doing dr arn
was talking about tennessee asking for a
hundred
party initiative charter schools um
that's a game changer once you have that
and
and and all of a sudden the governor
leaves who's fantastic the governor
lee's gone
and it's a liberal that comes in there
you can't you can't bring
uh put the the the animals back in the
barn
um so yeah it's happening but it only
happens when the leadership is good
where the leadership is bad
i mean all you have to do is read the
articles under a pandemic
i don't care take the top ten five
largest urban districts
school districts in the united states of
america florida has five
all five of ours were open with
face-to-face instruction for all
children
the other five were closed until most of
them until january or february
and some are still closed today boston
chicago los angeles it's still
you're never getting those kids back
you're never getting those kids back and
so
but why i mean it's the difference
between gavin newsom and and
ron desantis you know cuomo was writing
books
about how to survive in a pandemic while
arguably 10 000
senior citizens died because of his
failures while ron desantis was studying
the
science and the metrics and the first
thing he did was protect the nursing
homes
it leadership's everything so yes under
good leadership we're making great
strides
question in the back thank you sir
one thing um i've wondered it seems like
a very ideological
debate that we're having and maybe not
always connected to
outcomes in a beneficial way and
it appears that quite frequently
it's hard to find common ground
what have you found to be a good
argument or a good way to approach this
discussion
that helps you find common ground with
people who may
have an adverse reaction to your
ideological position
i'm trying not to i i grew up in an
irish catholic family with five so
dinner table is always like arguments
and and my the way i have found common
ground is uh
literally and dr arndt again was talking
about this i have fought
the way i find common ground because
they will roll over you when we wanted
to open up schools
in september the entire agency
was surrounded you know we have a small
courtyard the entire agency was
surrounded by
literally um fake coffins
headstones you know grim reaper was
walking around the building
i mean and and they sued me um
you know to to keep schools closed um i
think i
i always say i'm always open i'll sit
down with anybody and have that
discussion
i do think who i'm describing though
i think if you're talking about people
you know can
can joe biden sit down and have a
conversation
um with a with a tom cotton yes i think
they can
um but i'm talking on on that that outer
side and really it's
it's outer left there's no negotiation i
don't think antifa wants to sit down and
have a conversation with me about
how can we make the society better um
and again dr arne gave a great analogy
about
the warring in the streets in germany
pre-world war ii was between the nazis
and the germans and
the communists and the nazis ultimately
won and hitler became the leader of the
nazi street fighters
that's what i think you're seeing with
antifa and what have you that what they
want is
is complete um upheaval
and and so those people i just don't
i'll sit with you know
where where necessary i'll sit with them
but i think we have to be efficient and
and very strategic in how we go about
what we're doing
and um the the war will be won in
education if we can get education right
we can
um have kids be literate and then
understand what it means to be a
a self-governing citizen in a
self-governing country
um we'll win it back um i think doctor
on again i
keep quoting we just spent some time
with him but he said that you know
education is our sword you know that's
our that's our weapon our weapon is our
is education and we can do it we can get
it right
um and i do think i
i always try not to sound biased but i
do think that we are willing to sit down
we are willing to have those
conversations and we are willing to look
at the science
you know all the the the far left
yelling us about science science science
but when it came to opening
up schools every single thing that has
been said in january and february posted
biden administration taking over in the
cdc and all the changes and now it's
okay it's safe to open kids don't
transmit kids don't
aren't in harm's way all of that science
was 100 available to us
in june and july which is what we made
our decision on
um so i think we're willing to have
those conversations we're willing to be
rational we're willing to look at the
science and the facts
i mean the truth is the truth this room
believes in truth we believe it's
objective
um you know i had lunch yesterday with
janet and david whalen and they were
talking about how they were educated in
kansas and and i just thought it was a
great line but her professor used to say
all the time to the doubters in the
class as they're
going through learning the the great
books and he would say
here's what i'll tell you fire is hot
water is wet
and rocks are hard i mean but the the
it's just a beautiful way of saying the
truth is the truth
um but that they want to deny that i
mean the whole argument in the in
university campuses there is no truth
it's all subjective
and so there there's going to be
a battle and so sit down have that
discussion be transparent be open
always i think all of us would do that
but the way we're going to get to where
we're going to get
is by fighting every step of the way
it will be a battle we will have to
fight and as winston churchill says
all the other virtues are great but
courage is the most important because
without it none of the others are
possible
question to the speaker's left hi
state senator lena tyson here hi thank
you for being here so
grateful michigan has lost
65 000 kids from our public education
system
largely because of the shutdown i'm
wondering excuse me
if florida experienced any kind of a
loss and what that looked like
since you stayed open i would assume
that that probably not
but more than the normal loss
the uh we track that and so
um and and i'm just talking students
because we
we have as michigan does how we do our
funding form
there's weights for certain things so
one student could actually account for
two
students just based on the weights and
funding but if you look at actual
students we there was maybe a five or
ten thousand difference
and a lot of them when we tracked them
down because we rewarded the districts
for tracking them down
most of them were parents who went to
the homeschooling mode without properly
withdrawing their child
um so so it comes up as an extra 10
000 law students but we found that most
of them were home school students
but every year we lose um 10 to 15 000
students we are
a growth state thousand people come
pretty much every single day
but we also have a lot of families
leaving especially when we have a
hurricane michael come through the
panhandle
you'll see a lot of the low-income
families will go to alabama or
mississippi
and so we always have that but we do a
good job of tracking them
and because we were open it was easier
to do so because
you know basically if 95 kids came back
to a you know a
a class or a school we knew that there
was supposed to be a hundred we could
immediately know here's the five we
gotta find
it makes it a lot easier when when
you're tracking them as opposed to
i mean look at los angeles they have you
know online synchronous learning
you know asynchronous only they've tried
everything and i think there's some days
where only like 15 or 20 percent of the
students are actually clicking
in online i mean just a disaster it's
i've said to people it's not it's it's
not sad
it's not frustrating what's going on in
the rest of the country is criminal
if if i was to go to any one of your
homes and grab your kids and
put them in solitude and say they can't
hang out and they have to do all this
stuff
i'd be arrested for a host of different
crimes
and then if i said to their parents and
by the way you're gonna have to close
down your small business you can't work
anymore because
you're gonna have to take care of your
kids i'd be arrested for a host of
crimes what's going on in the rest of
the country
is literally criminal taking and
criminal behavior
the question to the speakers left
hi my question regards the curriculum
and
what role the state has if any in
oversight of local school curriculums
and i have a
little story that i'd like to insert
here two thanksgivings ago
we had a family celebration and i found
out that there were going to be two
children
when it won 8 110 attending so my
husband and i thought it would be really
cute i have these costumes
to dress up as pilgrims we thought that
the kids when we opened the door and
they saw two pilgrims and it was
thanksgiving that they get a kick out of
it right
so we've kept the costumes on for the
entire day so we're sitting around the
table in our pilgrim's costume you know
my hat my husband had the hat i had my
little
with my and um we finally this the
ten-year-old
at one point looked at us and um because
i'm starting to give the story of the
indians and the pilgrim in the meal and
you know
the engines really helped out the
pilgrims who because it was their first
winter you know i get the whole spiel
that we grew up with
and this 10 year old looks at me and he
says
didn't the pilgrims come to kill the
indigenous people
i mean talk about putting a damper on
thanksgiving
so there we were dressed as pilgrims and
in the eyes of this little boy
he had learned that the pilgrims came to
kill the indigenous indians
so we tried to set things straight but
then you know we changed the topic and
the mother went
well you know they do go to a
progressive school
and i said well i'm i i was just shocked
to find out
to even hear the word indigenous from in
the mouth of an of a 10 year old
you know why wouldn't you say they came
to kill the indians i said it sounds to
me like your progressive school is
indoctrinating
and that was the end and then we just
kind of move on so then then i found out
about the 1619 project that i had never
heard of before
so all these years our children have
been reading books being taught books
that present things a certain way and i
i bet you
that a good majority of parents are
totally unaware
oh and by the way they didn't know what
the mayflower was
because i got into the boat they came
over on this boat you know the mayflower
no we haven't heard about the mayflower
okay
so how are you addressing and that's
just one example you know critical
race theory um is another one that's
permeated our curriculums
who who decides what books
are going to be used in instruction
that's a great question so we've just
fought that battle we still fight it on
a daily basis
and there's multiple ways you can fight
it so first we rewrote all our standards
so we're on every we're on a standard
five-year book adoption
or seven-year book adoption depending if
you had in you know certain science
years um and so we disrupted the whole
book adoption because we rewrote our
whole standards
um and we rewrote them you know with the
science of reading we
have the first in the nation um a civics
reading list from
from uh kindergarten all the way through
12th grade um
we have a reading list for all other
courses um
it's it's just content rich and
the quick you know anecdote which you
guys know well i probably stole it from
you guys when you came
but they have you know basically kids
who are ones and twos or functionally or
somewhat illiterate
and they have the three fours and fives
and they put them in a room and they
give them a reading comprehension exam
and it's on baseball all of the ones and
twos play baseball none of the three
fours and fives play baseball and then
they grade and see how they did on the
reading comprehension
and the ones in two scored four zero
forty percent higher than the three
fours and fives even though
they couldn't read nearly as fast or as
well or at all
but they understood the game and so
obviously content matters that's the
vocabulary matters as much as the
decoding
and so we rewrote all of our standards
we did all of that stuff
and then we do a book adoption which
were now all the publishers and the
publishers are just infested with
liberals
and so we would have to say to them in
our bid specs we're not going to take
care or approve your bid
unless you have you know a certain
percentage of our reading list has to be
in your in your c
in your text you can have no whole
language or you know
uh blended literacy or anything and it
has to be the science of reading and we
went through a whole criteria
and then then when the books came in we
you know evaluate the books on the
on the criteria we said but i was just
saying last night to
um the folks that we had dinner with
that um
so now the books have come back and
they've you know you don't think
and of course kovit had so we were a
little bit distracted but i didn't think
to say okay and keep all of the crazy
liberal stuff out
and so now we literally have them and
they hide it
in what's you know social emotional
learning so it doesn't say
critical race theory but you could
definitely have a teacher who teaches
critical race theory so now we have to
go back to him and say if it's
electronic we want it out
and then on top of that we're passing a
rule this coming month that says you
can't
for the 185 000 teachers um you can't
indoctrinate students with stuff that's
not based on our
on our our standards the new best
standards so all of that
but you have to police them on a daily
basis it's 185 000 teachers in a
classroom with
anywhere from 18 to 25 kids and if
you're not physically there in the
classroom
i will tell you it's it's working in the
universities and it's starting to work
in
i've censored or fired or terminated
numerous teachers for
doing that i'm getting sued right now in
duval county which is jacksonville
because
it was an entire classroom memorialized
to black lives matter
we made sure she was terminated and now
we're being sued by every one of the
liberal left groups
for freedom of speech issues um and and
and i say to them you know to the point
your question
try to find common ground i'll say to
look let's not even talk about whether
it's right or true
or good what you have there my issue is
when you
you're a third grade teacher and only
you know 42 percent 41
of your kids are on grade level why
don't you do me a favor get them on
grade level and then we'll have that
discussion
make them at least be able to read and
understand it first um to try to not act
like i'm you know
radical right or whatever they want to
call me but it's a it's a constant
vigilant fight
it's a it's a terrible battle we now
have time for one last question
thank you for coming all the way from
sunny and free florida to join us here
yesterday you rivaled florida
the weather followed you here dr arn
often talks about
education being a partnership between
the educators
and the parents we've had this huge
influx of federal cash
what are some steps that florida is
taking to help
partner with parents and empower parent
and parents specifically with
some of the federal money that's been
coming in we've taken most of the
federal money that wasn't
you know they've gotten more
prescriptive in the last arp
plan but before that we basically have
been using it to invest
on that pre-k all the way to third grade
in massive ways involving parents and
then on top of that
i'm trying to grab hold of the the
learning gain losses that we have from
and
the learning gap i mean in florida we
have so i asked my staff
at you know right now on the third grade
fsa we're at about 58 percent three
fours and fives
42 below um partially or fully
illiterate
which i i say that because one and two
just doesn't it sounds innocuous i want
you to understand these kids are never
coming out of that for the most part
so um and then i said okay if i wanted
to at the current growth rate
so i take that you know we are
absolutely if you go to any of these
national conferences they'll tell you
florida leads the
country in education reform and what
we're doing
most other states copy and most stats
you know we have the number one ap test
takers we have the
number two performance and this is all
pre-covet i think you're going to see us
go to number one in most
most categories because of our kids
having that instruction but
besides that so florida being doing well
in reform
what would it take at our current growth
rate you know because
you know we you know 50 we were started
at way below we were like uh
i used to joke it's a terrible thing i
hope i don't offend anyone from
mississippi but i used to joke thank god
for
back in 1998 thank god there was
mississippi otherwise we'd be dead last
in every category but mississippi was i
think dead last and everything
but um what would it do to close the to
close the achievement gap
and what would it take to get um
non-title one or non-low-income kids
to 90 proficiency in third grade and
what would it take
for title one or low-income kids to get
to 90 proficiency
um by third grade and the staggering
number is
to take basically two-parent
middle-class and up
kids to get them from their current
state to 90
proficiency in florida would take 100
years it would take
200 years to get low-income kids there
and the overwhelming problem i mean
there there is an organized injustice
that's going on in education with
basically um our problem is title our
low-income kids and you
and with all the barney schools you're
starting to see um
the classical schools get more and more
of these low-income kids
um to your question sir that now it's
going to really help i mean we're going
into the
non-traditional sector of these students
and so um what you're seeing though with
with the that huge chasm
is unless you have just complete
clayton christensen disruption um you're
going to have this organized injustice
which really is this
i say it not publicly but the bulk of
those
low-income kids are majority
minority and these are our struggling
readers the our struggling readers are
overwhelming majority poor
of that poor population overwhelming
majority minority of that
population overwhelmingly majority
african-american so there is an
injustice that's going on it's not
you know instead of having marches and
and riots and what have you there's
something that could be done
um but it's not being done but the more
we empower those parents
um and what we found in the choice
movement people would literally say to
us when we started the the
transformational choice back in the 1998
there'd be you can't literally these
would be things that the left would say
to us
um you can't do that you can't just you
know turn over a voucher and give it to
a single mom who doesn't even have a job
or an education it'll be a disaster
they would literally say that to us i
mean a patently racist statement
um and yet when we did that what we
found is guess what every parent does
every parent cares about their kids far
more than a bureaucrat sitting at some
administration building in
in city hall and they do care and they
do
move with their feet to the point that
the charter school movement in florida i
can't say this for the rest of the
country
we have more minority students in our
public charter schools than we do in our
traditional schools
and we have the same and sometimes
higher low-income kids
in our charter schools than we do in our
traditional public schools and all are
public
because parents will get involved and
they will make a difference and the
results are anywhere from 10 to 15
on a bad day better than in the
traditional public schools
so that we know that the more you
involve those parents
you will have better outcomes for the
students please join me in thanking
commissioner corcoran
thank you
you